I was going to look to the fact that
i've recently with Murphy so thank you
very much congratulation this is what we
call working together okay we're
together now they tell you another story
and I'm telling it gets myself as much
as anything cuz I'll even married just
over a week and I know you discovered
that i'm not perfect it comes a great
shot it's all again in the last battle
on earth and everyone on earth dies and
waits outside again in judgment so God
comes and says I want the men to make
two lines one line is from the men been
dominated their women on earth and the
other line is for the men that were
dominated by their women so you get the
picture also I want all the women to go
with some Peter with that said and done
the next time you look so women have
gone and there are two lines the line of
men who were dominated by their women is
thousands of miles long and in the line
of men who dominated their women there
was only one man God gets angry he says
you men should be ashamed of yourselves
I created you in my image and you are
all whipped into shape by your mates
look at the only one of my sons who
stood up and made me proud learn from
him tell them my son how did you manage
to be the only one in this line well the
man replies I don't know my wife told me
to stand here
is coming better straight in a world
that often seems less secure than we
imagined we can change the great for
peace and respect for all human beings
of whatever creed gender nationality
religion status or position in society
or relationship with us and we
particularly continue to think of
Holocaust Memorial Day we also remember
and pray for a sense of harmony with
this creation planet that sustains and
gives us all and more than most of us
need the rose resources to keep us alive
and noted as long as received good of
our neighbor yet it's also courage also
reminds us of its natural power and
capacity to dwarf our efforts to subdue
the immense riches and wonders of our
world as we use the power responsibility
to govern there was the ever mindful of
the weak vulnerable needing oppressed in
our communities may God perhaps be in
our thinking as council members tonight
discuss the medium term financial
strategy always hoping to rise to the
challenge deliver in unity and be
committed to the community for the girl
and benefit of always repeating the
season and preparation inlet looking
towards Easter and we also offer our
prayers for heather glen who is unwell
tonight
to be with us we pray that she may
recover and be with us as soon as
possible he said for the slowest lips
and blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit payments now
and always Tommy don't tell her I said
that trade on the internet later but its
its armies are short and forth a
medicine
ok
notice this amount of trouble we're
delighted to even introduce you today
Mary Ellen part 1episode be taking art
and fries with see ryan tedder item one
the apology adapted upon interactions
Thank You chairman we have apologies in
the office and counselors italy in
Council and Katherine from making any
other concentrated villains are so in
Council of cars are part of the year the
Galactic run okay fine too we should get
roaches of interest and very much okay
then we go shoujo item three other line
and introduce this
first of all start by just even an
apology first wattle over here and we
voted it in the error in the time
constraint I trying to get a detailed
piece work completed with next number of
small my rights as we go through and we
don't believe it sort of takes away from
the overall content and key points
within report that lose to that I just
wanted to quickly bring to your
attention a 10.3 state so it does make
reference to the fact that it's included
in the council touch rather than the
council tax administration and also to
make reference to the fact that some of
the portfolio holders are not
appropriately aligned in the report so
again just to give apology people that
go through some of the details in the
report so then just posted on the
handles the strategy itself makes it on
the view is making cities 2021 keeper is
really trying to ensure that we have a
five year platform on which to deliver
the actual business and objective
sentence of the grade by everyone but
also quietly listen to that we start on
the journey to being self-sufficient and
forward in the future and design
services that we envisioned only
appropriate ones for opportunities so I
think I just wanted to quickly just talk
about some of the data a seaport break
within but it's giving it a very quick
summary you're perfectly adopted in in
the drafting the antelope or budget was
25 initially not to incorporate any
milta fishin see so we lose had to the
current 2015-16 for cards when you do
such as I starting point as opposed to
taking a to more traditional coach and
going back to the original base budget
this was around trying to ensure that
forecasted our terms starting point upon
which we then bill topic we now focus
collectively on what we called the no
nose so again ticking and bit more in
detail about the impact of inflation on
the five-year forecast and again in cups
of some of the pressures and growth
flavors that will be familiar with that
were coming through the details on the
service service areas books on fees and
charges and finance financing of the
routine cut tomatoes and similarly
reflecting within the some terms with
the changes that are being imported in
the airport and government grants as a
result of that we are inspired by Japan
just shy of being in town
I can report again is doing legal in
process and that's changed quite
considerably over time I think the thing
that I wanted to just be clear that we
need you as a fact that they're all of
being known unknowns and the unknown num
nums and for artistry is just fun to
think about the fact of the budget at
the moment still carries with it a
number of risk so the risk around
potential trainable and pension
actuarial valuation due in a few years
common you still have some elements of
incentivize funding incorporated within
the core strategy and and there were
things that will come along to actually
change the landscape there's my fancy
new burdens that's actually announced to
run the course of the five-year plan and
also applies to be basic notices that
just pop up I'm in terms of what a
related conditions etc as a result in
frontentia that we prepare for that with
the gain adult approach where we try to
increase the level of 20 entrances that
we have two such things and that's that
one again we have a report and rudeness
of Latino we increase in 1,000,000 1.5
million of the time in after the five
years on fire and also that we created
some a large deserves a focus on the
specifics that we know can ensure that
we have the perfect occasion quarter
so they those are the key things in
terms of how they emergencies
incorporated leave all that then focus
on some of incentive funding one of the
things that I noticed when I first
joined your photos was that we have
incentive funding of which we have built
into our base budget I wanted try to
move to a position where we were
actually reliant on core funding for
poor activity and utilize an incentive
funding in a slightly different way I'm
happy to say that the approach doctor
now enables us to actually utilize that
slightly differently and dissolve
investments that have actually generate
economic growth within within our
communities and also enable us to invest
in things that are actually going to
help us you staying or going forward the
era that I sort of wanted to change the
attention you may actually be noted
supplemental
that we have the budget at present is
based on the traditional financial
stress levels in the 17th December the
final settlement is always using
terrible it is to actually on the fifth
member that didn't arrive until late
last night and so we sort of had a a
little it to sort of very quickly
analyze what does that mean mean for us
in Watford and and I summarizes in the
supplementary pagan that you give the
table today I think when we met recently
we talked a little bit about the
assumptions that are being made by
central government in terms of our
funding ability and we indicated that
there are assumptions that that move
away from a council tax reform to it a
additional support be provided through
council tax this has come through or
evidently now some of the changes
further changes that we've proposed in
the final settlement there's an
acceptance that and that the change in
the two percent referendum threshold and
we've had some County didn't go far
enough and that there's an ability for
district councils to increase the county
tax they charge up to a new Reverend
versions of five pound actual md county
tax base and what I'm basically
incorporated in the analysis
none of that but also given you break
down the first line of the assumptions
that are based around a two-point roots
that house attacks growth and it
increases align to CPI at one point
seven five percent so that it gives an
indicative for two thousand six total of
six point six or seven and which
compares to the video that we have 6.5
your budget at present but to further
key changes that I just sort of wanted
to bring your attention within the
financial settlement arrived yesterday
one was around the new homes bonus and
whilst we classes an acknowledgement
that the new homeowners is still under
consultation what's being proposed that
this date is the revision based on the
envelope that's going to be aligned for
each of the financial years and a
program turn of the funding based on
what we receive 16 17 so it's sort of
saying actually completely Paris on
reductions in this area but again and
the given index is bigger so I think are
approaching anything bad shape ensuring
that that's a private basis and business
was a rough one the other change that
was announced
there was a new transition grant and if
you recall there was a change in the
methodology of which the directly report
grant was being reduced and we thought
about babbit rock saluting quite
severely patent with a significant
reduction amounting to ninety six
percent in the first two years has been
a recognition that in many areas just to
see the 23 to absorb within the first
two year an additional funding of a
hundred and fifteen minutes been set
aside of course the crosspiece but the
first two years of the the changes and
that equates to 30 95 90 per year for
Roger so that's an improvement in income
every hand aunt is accounted this
evening so today we're going to
summarizes the financial settlement for
movement and also what we had built in
torrance ers so the composition for
ourselves then is to actually revised on
new homes bonus incentives bigger in
line with the lowest of the common
denominators so actually I there are
four past if it was lower or the actual
endler that they've provided refinancing
year but also to incorporate in the
funding the 95,000 transition funding
and actually as I looked about reduce
the warrants on this earth to do the
budget gap for those years so again
subject to approval today will be
the nation that that's one of the
changes that we've revised in the NT
means something finally just a suspect
that actually the lead propositions
themselves the publishers themselves
over the five years amount to 2.5
million the focus has been on on 1670
and ensuring that we have road latitude
diligent undertaken and have a balanced
budget for 1617 trying to create a
platform the future years which is of
the opportunity to be able to actually
move forward with some legless certainty
but recognizing that some of those
concepts that are put forward to future
years may need to have some further work
undertaken madness and photo Judaism's
to finalize so the request for today
will be to endorsing for the 16 17 and
agree that we continue to finalize the
work that we need to on the residual
technologies that we have identified in
the future years
okay I'll take your questions in British
Top Cat asante come before I get started
can I just done it and this a 3.1 17 and
a change like movie the figures are page
329 on seven or with regard car parking
charges charges are increase on the
basis of a change in the nighttime rape
moving the time from 7 to a 9 p.m.
looking at first the second little
subcategory works its way down the hall
what I would like to move is that the
parking band mains to stop at seven
blocks of parking charges remain up
until seven not until nine but the three
hour charge moves from Jim pounds 42 to
power 60 and the four hour charge moves
two pounds 90 23 pounds 30 there is a
very good
from to 40 to 60 to 90 to 330 but and
the revenue generated by that would be
the same as the revenue generated by the
figures that you see presenting the war
you and mr. Haughton has confirmed that
those those figures do match up but
obviously deserve okay you should study
their main that may be important that's
the first element members there's an
awful lot of us here tonight there's a
lot of us here tonight because we know
this is the the key part of the council
yo it's where the crucial decision is
named about balancing or revenue and I
are estranged and that the important
thing is that work balancing you must
set sure that we do that it's been a
difficult way forward and it's a
challenging process of the quad
bomb-proof there are some very big
changes that have been faced and as
Maybury say
there's a lot of variables that we have
and some very raw food out now is known
so we know the mountain don't know it's
a difficult time to be dealing with
council finances when we go through a
very open process no member has been
excluded from this process we have got
presented to us tonight to egg way
forward with a series of foundation
starting on page three point two nine
and as you have seen one of those ways
forward does include arrived in the town
some tags but the rise it is because
we're not afraid to make the difficult
decision decisions to allow us to go for
the services that we need to provide for
our residents when I'm extravagant to
this we're not looking to build up our
reserves to anything that is
unreasonable in fact we are keeping very
much within the sit for guidance for our
reserves it's a large document and I'm
sure there will be sent it to date about
it tonight so I shall leave fluorescence
of that steak place
there is it members either a seconder
for the proposition foot by event is
free mentor for gamers way to be arms
it's a bit too much I other day long
okay all right everything nobody mention
proposition to a couple others the
others in to do is the second the motion
pathology that's quite a name on the
list members our placements been
seconded on the police across parts as
well so that many sensation that let's
prep sail out of little easy and sick
having said that [ __ ] when I break it
would be done twice I think members
rules congratulate Antilles Marie but
all the work we can achieve put into
this Anthony and I officers and indeed
the members in coming forward with a
budget that actually looks to the future
the future could be a bleak thing when
you look at council finances because
we're in a situation where we're having
less and less income if you like as a
council we are getting more and more the
thruster pods and there will be with
these for us to process as the leases
already say but we could be in a
situation where we can get more for less
I think this does achieve that I think
that it's great that we've got low
investment ball and that's crossed our
teacher I think it's genuine enthusiasm
for all
sections of the council to make sure
that is its success going into the
future and I'm really pleased about that
Sharon I think as a budget as I say does
look into the future it really does
encompass all that we that we can know
that will happen in the future that is
known at the moment I'm pleased to hear
about the new parents that are coming
forward but nevertheless we have a real
challenge it's the future as far as what
we want to do so I do commend the budget
churning and going forward thank you
okay so joe Manchin sound like the voice
is going to go for here maybe if I see
people all the towns left side over the
other places okay I also like to echo
has couples that about I'm really
pleased to have such a include five-year
plan in front of us it's much better
than we've had in the past I don't seek
to the blame people for not producing as
managed services we have had the
opportunity of new officer we won by off
one officer looking at this wiggity has
come up with the team not just a
financial services and various and
directors to actually come up with a
view of the future please hit point out
that the concept savings were just what
they are there is there is a lot of
peace ability work to go into those and
we should accept them as simply being
you know those are kept you can happen
as they are only examples one of the
things that our residents always look to
and I don't think as a resident that
hasn't asked me by recently who hasn't
said what's the council tax game free so
they're always concentrating on the
current year and it is the current year
that we know most about so don't be
surprised that I'll be talking about
current year rather than the immediate
future because I know they're going to
go through stringent for the tests I
won't be opposing this budget because
the majority of residents already know
where we are and how we got here they
knew last year there would be severe
cuts in local government funding when
they reach the polls in the general
election so no surprises no the lips are
occurring here still needs explaining to
in terms of Reggie understand sadly they
won't all be as interested as we were to
go through do the multitude of pages and
see the picture as a whole so one of
them is actually sought to bring some of
these headlines into terms that are
normalized with each other
some of the increases are in council tax
immunity 1.93 percentage siren fees and
charges and is a very good schedule for
that and others have involved reserves
and we've already heard that out result
[ __ ] raided as much as we expected
nevertheless he will take it takes a
brave brave man to real this former very
quick view and we have the press here
who will obviously who is interested
soon as anyone to actually get that life
view of the budget I have converted fees
and charges increases and reserves
increasing reserve uses into council tax
improvements so we're actually starting
with the budget survey where our
resident sixty percent actually turn
down and say we be happy with small
increase and that's what we begin we've
given them a small increase of 1.9 three
percent but of course they have been
changed should allow us to go further
than that but that's the proposal here
I'm quite happy to support all of our
fees and charges this is a total of
business charges in the schedule are
expecting to hear further 400,000 pounds
this year if you convert back to council
tax being found out six point six or
seven so equal 1.93 there's no prizes
for keeping up
he's got the 6.6 in that six point six
percent council taxes I quarters for
1000x there are car parking charges
those are parking charges in themselves
represent a two point four percent
council tax so it's significant and
particularly significant on top of the
other people through two years ago we've
taken only 50,000 pounds from outer the
government very finely metal that
transition in their favor and that in
itself is nearly one percent council tax
in itself so to cushion the effects of
the government cuts we have provided in
50,000 pounds which is around point
eight-five upset nearly one percent
announced ourselves one of the things I
hugely regretted up this settlement is
had comparison and our position against
other local councils I was very
disappointed to publish lobster to some
much worse than our neighboring
authorities as sadly the reason for it
seems to be that because we thought
ahead without poor strategy with
divisions and built the houses that we
now penalize because we were able to
generate more council tax so therefore
our settlement to speak over the katana
more particular they haven't even given
up their their green belt and they've
got more cash fattys were incredible I'm
not happy with that at all
interestingly if you add up these
numbers 1.93 point 6.85 then if I'm
right and some of you checked it for me
then we get to 79 9.38 sin so we'll be
presenting our budget have current
budget out 2016-17 budget we need to
tell our residence but it's not just 1.9
three percent which made make them feel
very comfortable but it's actually 9.38
same bearing in mind that a number of
increases have taken place outside of
the council tax figure itself but in
fees and charges and use of reserves I
am going to leave it to residents to
judge whether they're happy with that
and I hope the people in press will
report it accordingly so that they know
transparently what has actually happened
Jen I'm not going to i'm not going to
pose as budget we are where we are and
we've got here because of continued
application of austerity measures there
are many other views on austerity and
this will leaves on that but never that
fat would be artist and as you can
we have to respond to it otherwise we
couldn't continue to buy their services
as they currently are and provide us
back into the future so that means safe
I agree with the budget can be 5
reporter hm
cancel Christmas
Thank You mr. as competition of service
we're eating like a lot to discuss us
begin are those small little unusual one
of the other questions involve some
others I ask what the odds worth
repeating two members looking page 306
the glove the apparently shows and grass
this year I've shoplifted that's not the
way is to do with the charging of room
hyperbole so we can list a short but
there is enough evidence 19 another talk
about the cut end up in macys budget
but something rock we salute the next
year but that's not a nice car parking
sometimes it's delightful ridiculously
certain that I spent last slide 11
restaurant or bar by the only had a half
my built talking to people where they
start their mouths about post x six
hours and / 12 that is none of them
looking certain abilities the number of
the Sun felt most of their presence
before and it would hit them hard others
are considering our staff that's a page
that they have to pay for Parkinson has
to start across those are concerns about
sleep party source of my concern that
people trying to see if the faculties
have to pay so i can see what two sides
of it there are those traders to drive
say our customers have to pay why should
the restaurant to pay but we already
know there are people who were not happy
to make it a shot full song is that
they're my principal car party ever come
and we would lose restaurant right I
mean the most people who will not come
as a peaceful that's don't I got it it
spoils very easily having to pay so i
felt hopefully rush it was like actually
I'm glad to see is the ending of
delighted to hear that I'm also pretty
single bit more than buddies city says
government we have a lot of hard work
and stuff and not only the finest
department I share capsule nice and
competition food but people he's well
pen but we've got softer lovett a
significant successes we've got the
public who are working hard as well and
we they're very high put over the best
chance of the country at lady council
have but 30 capsule tank
we make it work with my finger and we do
our best we are not being true two third
of a sudden and if I hope you got one
regrets and I haven't had anybody
actually criticized Adonis use it for
you to write about it I notice even eat
the opposite support on page 34 bottom
which is about raw such changes are
unusual unexpected here I think that is
fairly delicate criticism of the
government operating it's not easy to
say if a restauranteur could complain we
hadn't been such a thing about account
about half times we can service at the
government you are treating like that's
why marks where they live their
independent label conservatives you are
treating us like month and gospel is
taking conservative councillors type of
behavior are uncounted in recent and you
are having a hard time and that causes
prophetic back to mr. Osborn properly we
want to count on me to fairly and mobile
yeah so I would support the capital
passing game tonight as I said I'm
concerned about the cutting class next
year though these necessary hopefully
clearly having what nieces knife and we
can avoid that next year if it was one
other [ __ ] white half eighth step in
with more looks all across the services
of membership so we know not be sent
packing plants peristalsis but my son
trivial but it hasn't paid for houses
plan applications and that very limited
so thank you for the thing and give me a
little time sure unless there's a
Michael boy behavior I would like to
echo cancellations comments and ciphers
going on do not oppose this budget in
fact some of the concepts being a 5 2016
17 onwards for ideas that we put forward
as a brick laughs here something
something so I'm taste similarly technol
dog however if you have these motions
over sound a specific increasing fees
it's a bit of bounce a balanced budget
some of them have been addressed by
Kansas Smith earlier but Manning I do
have preserved about decreasing parking
shoulders still our previous roof
offices and feel assured the increasing
chance to the extent of the time perfect
evening which one down there is not
relevant will not have a decorated
exhalation tray Rozsival loads of the
officers who completed i am breathing
lease
the price of ticket is not prohibitive
to the use of color fox protectively it
doesn't affect them also charges
weekends in popular to the t color does
not try with the original reason for
introducing as we're approaching talvez
discourage all day parking by commuters
and open workers to free up space in
tunisia uses so I'm sure how that fixing
it the outside for a moment I do have
problems and other fantasy football
dessert for instance view are we
recalibrate song contest has a great
relationship of the 33 years in heaven
how much are what's changed out the
wheel okay which others women good lord
increases income about 5,000 pounds a
year so increase previously because that
Lee struggle to do so so our suspicions
as the back office in Evansville around
Cara garden these figures on for other
of the budgeting aspects as well and our
people are habitual purposes of the
complication trinkets old old netbook
settlers in future years which I know
but emotionally I think if it reaches me
not to mention this at this time there
are other income generation ideas such
as charging for green beans
cross-ownership throat through ontario
shown renegotiations reducing something
collections and plugs or puppy toilets
which raising his head game that's not
already asleep confident these the
values in these changes and aspirations
on a group or concepts
these words are cheap bull which oh
there will be three their move your wipe
it from what the concept of house is
about this was the interpolation 5 2000
Service addition to choose among their
own doctor program can help you moving
to an area where charges and fees such
as part of your being used to subsidize
other services juicy cusp it makes this
council quite a forgotten by the
subjective government of this country
and obvious issue of a seat sir pacific
and elisa private and i may say
something different but when we see the
subsidies council they they are
supporting the carts and now I shouldn't
have there for supporting the
preservative government we think they're
full sociable for the purpose of this
council as I said all of the opposing
which is budget several microsomes
outfit charges I feel I'm being saying
currently doesn't yep charity for
clarification from council Smith with
respect to his original motion which
we've actually voted on and that it does
incorporate the three and four hours
which comes under the mix including
protesters that includes rupture and the
fact that it does I didn't prepare to
say to everybody else is fair enough
regards
from the losing that's all the questions
we go to watch in 1759 on page 39
look too easy remind you that is the
item from them set more than this here
we come
ok
we recommend it it's a recorded vote now
so I turn left on that is will be
referred to the next capsule may tell
you something beginning in first item
there under Section 17 are we agreed on
a budget item two and their costs of
this type of program the item for the
section 151 person but insulting dude
that's just to be noted
I should shake Santa partition that's it
complete it skip it counselor black
cattle Burton oh ok let's the missus
butcher
that's a couple that's your dry for
cancer Gibson Oh
councillor Griffin tends to mrs. Hale
cancel a hater or counselor hazelwood Oh
cancel hook quack
customers is holy
casa hoy cancel her soon cool
cancer yani castle normal cool
cuz to mrs lammle
cancel Alex Oh
and solicit niacin oh
cansu Mason little photograph this for
cancel mrs. Howe Pearson Oh customary
council mrs. Dublin
cancel the job
cousin Sega's or cancel Smith
cancer softly
cancel the sensor cancel sorry oh that's
the scepter 4 cancelled or cancel the
web
customers western well my customers is
working for
if members that says Harry is 33 45
attention absolutely those elusive this
can happen Lupul Justin I think at
castro newsletter get this money making
thank you so that movie on many members
fighter might and just to remember that
there was a proposition loading this
item by cancer smith and including this
item so we're very very put the cherry
picker put my hope in things okay okay
why tonight at dinner pass green good
Martin 10 would be all the interval
after then it shall be further than it
council meeting item 12 really nice and
13 for noting the engine how to 14 for
noting and Bridget but the 15 conniving
that concludes the yet this is to the
same the hose I hope the meeting agenda
peed outside